This episode was supported by Skillshare.
Have you ever wondered how your brain would be better than the brains around you?
Well, if you are taller than those who stand by them, you may be smarter.
The researchers found that people who are taller are often the ones with higher incomes.
Which is supposed to be linked to self-esteem, social control
Or intolerance against the shortest people.
However, a study in 2009 indicated that older children have more
Highest scores in cognitive tests.
Or maybe you'll be the oldest among your brothers;
A study of 250,000 Norwegian military personnel found that the eldest son
He has an intelligence average of 2.3 points higher than his younger siblings.
This is not a genetic rule; it is a result of the parents' full interest in the early.
Did you get your food by breast feeding or bottle of milk when you were a child?
A Brazilian study tracked more than 3,000 children to the age of 30.
The researchers found that the duration and amount of breastfeeding is positively related
Intelligence, learning and income.
Speaking about drinking, drinking alcohol is bad for your brain, right?
Perhaps, but the most intelligent among us are the most likely to drink alcohol.
A study found that smart children in both the United Kingdom and the United States
They were more likely to consume alcohol in their old age
Similarly, another study assessed the IQ of 6713 people aged 11 years and followed them up to the age of 42,
The same was true for drug abuse such as cannabis, cocaine and amphetamines
And magic mushrooms.
Why do smart people resort to substances that may cause harm?
There is a hypothesis known as the Savannah-IQ hypothesis and assumes that the most intelligent people
They have unusual values ​​and priorities.
For example, most of us do our best during daylight hours
The uncommon time will be at night.
Therefore, the hypothesis states that the night people are the most intelligent among us,
This was confirmed by the longitudinal study of adolescent health.
If you find this information disturbing, it is likely ... you are very vigilant.
In a sample of 126 university students, verbal intelligence was found to be a positive indicator
To worry and think.
On the other hand, a person who does not worry about scoring high scores in the test of nonverbal intelligence.
Do you like daydreams?
A new study found that dreamers may be smarter, suggesting that people with effective minds
The capacity of their brains is greater than stopping thinking.
Left-handed?
A study involving 96 left-handed and 96 right-hand people, the result was left-handed
They scored higher degrees of creativity and also in differentiated thinking measures, that is, the ability to create new ideas
Of one principle.
If you want to develop your intelligence with your own hands, you do not have to decide whether you are right or right
He turned towards music lessons.
A study showed that verbal intelligence improved in 90% of preschool children after only 20 days of music training.
While you are in the midst of this, quit smoking.
Unlike other risks, a study of 20,221 young people aged 18 from the Israeli army
I found that IQ was lower in smokers compared to non-smokers.
Maybe abstinence is the reason?
The study evaluated 12,000 adolescents in grades 7-12, and found that students
Top IQ owners did not often have sex.
Another study found that this would extend for years to come.
In the United States, 80% of boys and 75% of girls lose their virginity at the age of 19,
While 87% of university students lose it.
However, these figures are lower in elite universities
At Princeton University 56% of her students had sex, 59% at Harvard, and 51% at MIT.
Finally, do you find this picture funny? * In the picture: "Every apple every day .. And will die anyway"
Congratulations, the dark comedy you have is positively associated with intelligence,
Regardless of age and gender.
It is important to remember that the link does not equal causality, but it is interesting
To check the variables related to intelligence.
How many variables apply to you?
Tell us that in the comments, if they apply to your experiences with the smart people you know.
If you want to become smarter than average, you should check out the amazing sponsor of this video
Skillshare
The site will offer you 0.99 cents for 3 months if recorded in January.
Skillshare is an online social platform for content creators, featuring more than 17,000 lessons on things like
Design, photography and even cooking.
I have personally experimented with the development of visual effects and editing skills.
It has been a great advance for me.
Currently enrolled in a writing course,
I try to write different things, like comedy scenes.
This helped me a lot.
Anyone can join any article!
Also, you can offer lessons with a membership of $ 10 per month, so you can use all the features of the site.
Click on the link in the description box and start learning.
Thanks for watching and following up, we will see you at the new video date next Thursday.
Translation: team translate @Autrjim